so let's talk about Russell Brand then
okay no I'm just kidding let's do it I'm
just kidding what are your thoughts on
Russell do you know him I know yeah I've
known Russell I don't know him well but
I've known Russell over 20 years I um I
think that he
uh I man it's there's a if there's smoke
there's fire I don't necessarily I don't
you who knows what goes on behind closed
doors at the end of the day so if people
are saying hey I was wronged by this
person and this person did X Y and Z
this okay I you you sure fine if that's
your experience and that's your
experience I I guess more to be revealed
at the end of the day I
do you know I do think it's uh an
interesting I'm not dogging any you know
anyone for not wanting to come forward
but it is it is always a scary thing
when accusations are made from Pure
anonity She's Come forward oh she has
now she is forward one of them one of
them is forward I I actually read her
whole thing and her name and everything
one of them is I there might be more
than one but I did uh I know there's
more than one accusation but I have seen
somebody identified come forward but to
the point it leaves when when
accusations like that are being made
from an anonymous source and people not
willing to come forward it then breeds
conspiracy theories well I know well
because his whole thing thing even
before it came out was this is going to
be an attack on him because he
challenges the media so I know that that
is a lot of people's standpoint sure
yeah I I think that he certainly has
ruffled a lot of feathers over the last
three years he has and and we do know
especially in this room that there are a
lot of powerful media entities and if
they do want to shut you up they
will yeah you know another big headline
that I wanted to ask you about um that
your mom actually commented on even
before the headline came out that the r
dest boy ever was Ashton Kutcher and I
know you worked with him right on the 70
show yeah yeah uh so that was we didn't
know the Ashton thing was going to come
out saw that before it well before you
say anything uh Ashton and uh Mila wrote
Because we do this before we have guests
on the podcast they they wrote a
tremendous letter telling us that you're
a great character all about you you're a
good friend you're trustworthy you got
these letters just it came from Ashton
remember we have we have a character
letter yeah he likes you uh I I don't I
I have I worked with him on that 70 show
and I never really socialized I would
see him out at events we all the time 20
years ago socially we were in the same
circles I was very good friends with
Danny Mason so like I was around all
like Wilma Danny and I we used to go to
the same Club every Friday they were
always the table next to mine like we
spent an an awful lot of time hanging
out together um so I but Ashton was
always he was never really hanging out
um was he rude little boy to you I I
think those are the words your mom used
right yeah yeah he was I what you know
my mom she's not the best at remembering
names my my my mom mispronounced my
wife's name for years probably still
does so when she said Ashton was a rude
little boy
she meant who no she didn't say Ashton
that's what that's who she was referring
she had him on her show uh she
mispronounced kcha K see kcha she she
mispronounced it and he and in the
commercial break he made a comment to
her
like why like who like
basically saying like well why are you
even in this job if you can't do it
essentially right and um which isn't
nice rude it is rude and especially to
someone of my you know an older woman
it's like okay like someone thinks my
mom should be in this job yeah and who's
not you yeah um she she is one who even
in these moments like that probably
wasn't Ashton's best moment but what I
love about Sharon is that and it must be
weird being her uh her Offspring because
we're all embarrassed As You Are by our
parents but all the time constantly she
will never I think I'm kind of like that
too but she'll never hold back no
because and and that's her honesty
that's what people love about her but
it's also the same that same thing that
propels her to notoriety is the thing
that gets her in trouble yes yeah it but
it's how she was raised being a a female
working in the music industry in the 60s
7s and 80s you had to be tough to
survive if we just talked about who her
father was yeah and if if it people
obviously things have got Leaps and
Bounds better but thing shitty things
still happen to people people and it was
far worse back then and she had to have
thick skin to survive and so she speaks
her mind if she feels disrespected or
anything she doesn't hold
back